hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the air things masters
we're starting off with the first game
that finished and um quite an exciting
one it's magnus crossing versus
vladislavia the second pair is uh of
course yani palmishi and
andrei sipenko we're gonna check out
what happened in that match as well but
but this one it's very quick and very
very concise so let's dive straight into
it magnus has the white pieces and for
the first game he goes for the english
opening he plays c4
e5 uh going for the for the king's
english variation and now g3 prepare
preparing to think it to the light
square bishop sorry about that
uh we have knight the c6 by artemis and
now bishop to g2 we have g6 also
preparing to think it to the dark square
bishop and knight to c3 bishop to g7 we
have e3 knight to f6 and now knight to g
to e2 so nothing new here this has all
been played many times before we have
castles castles by both players and now
d6 and finally striking in the center
with d4 we have a trait here captures
captures and rook to e8 and now h3
taking away the g4 square from black's
pieces we have knight to e7 uh trying to
this uh well light square bishop as it's
very strong so we're gonna play c6 and
d5 uh and here now the position has been
reached um uh quite a few times b3 is a
normal d five is a known move g four is
a normal but here magnus plays rook to
e1 and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how artemis deals with this uh we have
c6 of course as planned he wants to play
d5 and now we have bishop to f4 uh it's
also very interesting it does the bishop
belong on f4 or maybe a g5
but as it's magnus who prepared rook to
e1 he knows um
he knows uh his stuff so here we have d5
and uh how do you react to this magnus
closes it with c5 and if you're not sure
about this this is something that you
definitely don't do but here the players
were already incredibly low on time even
though it's only move 13 and advancing
the pawn in such a way abandoning the
struggle for the center allows it to be
undermined later on with a move like b6
but okay you're playing b for a4 so yeah
it can be played of course uh and now
artemis if you just continue for example
with knight to f5 maybe uh putting
pressure on this pawn but then let's say
g4 and knight h4
it's not really all that impressive for
white if you advance the pawns like this
uh but artemis decided to play knight to
e4 it seems to be a temporary pawn
sacrifice that turns out to be not so
temporary so here bishop captures an e4
magnus says thank you for this not so
temporary pawn the captures and now
knight captures on e4 and how do you
recapture the pawn well
knight to f5 now now we're attacking the
d4 pawn three times but the magnus plays
the absolute best move and that is
knights to c3 and now there's a problem
how do you recapture uh your pawn
uh because if you just capture it with
let's say knight capture sun and d4
there's bishop g5 and now look at this
the queen is attacked you have to react
to this and knight the f6 check is
coming it doesn't even matter what black
plays even if you play something like f6
we're still gonna capture on f6 and now
after bishop captures we're gonna
capture on e8 rook captures an e8 queen
captures on e8 and now bishop captures
on f6 and now black is completely busted
so instead after knight two to c3 we
have bishop to e6 bartimiev uh and now
bishop to e5 magnus now says you will
not be getting your pawn back how do you
play this
and okay we continue like nothing
happened uh b6 we are challenging this
advanced pawn uh b4 by magnus could be a
little bit dangerous as uh the rook is
still on a1 but that's why the bishop is
an e5 so you don't have to worry about
that uh b captures on c5 we have bishop
captures on g7 first uh king captures on
g7 and now d captures in c5 offering a
queen trade and a queen trait isn't good
for artemiv as he's done material but
also i if you decline this and move the
queen then it could be dangerous g4
chases away the knight queen can come to
d for the king is on g7 so everything is
starting to come together for for white
uh so here we have a5 challenging the b
for pawn but this move actually gives
the magnus a winning position so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolute best move for white here
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
new ways to advance that b-pawn and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show of course the move is pawn to b5
and i know what you guys are saying how
can it always be the b pawn well it
chess was just made that way from uh
from the very beginnings and if you're
thinking well couldn't we just trade
queens and then advance our b pawn well
not really if you trade queens first
let's say capture throw captures on the
e8 now b5 isn't all that impressive
because black has knight to d4 now going
after your b pawn but also just
threatening knight to f3 that's this
will uh cost white to the rook on e1 and
this will be impossible if the queen is
covering the f3 square so here white
really doesn't have anything better than
just advancing the pawn and allowing
this fork here uh we're going to capture
this with czech rook captures and okay
white can still uh say that i have a
pass b pawn
on the sixth string but it's not as
decisive so here magnus pushes b5 right
away that is the correct way to do it
now the
uh
the square is nicely nicely defended and
even if black trades first it doesn't
help we're just going to play rook e
captures on d1 and now this knight d4
move doesn't do anything because this
will not come with a fork we've just
moved the rook so instead after b5
artemia just captures it c captures on
b5 now we have knight captures on b5 and
now this knight is coming to d6
and not only that we have a past c pawn
so here we have bishop to d5 uh
declining the queen trade because you
really can't allow that but bishop d5
doesn't help our teammate in any way we
have knight b to d6 now attacking the
rook and the knight and the thing is if
you capture uh we're first going to
deliver this check and after this is
taken care of then we're going to
capture on d6 now the bishop is hanging
and the ones let's say the rooks get
traded off captures captures we're going
to move the bishop now let's say rookie
six and this is simply too much pressure
for uh anyone to handle uh that's gonna
be a winning game for magnus so instead
after rook uh knight b to d6 we have
rook to e5
uh saving the rook and now just knight
captures on f5 with check g captures on
f5 and queen to d4 a nice in-between
move as the rook is now pinned uh it
cannot move so f6 defending the rook and
now knight to d6 uh
just threatening rook captures on e5
removing the defender of the bishop and
then we're going to gobble up the bishop
so bishop back to c6 saving the bishop
and now rook captures an e5 so here f
captures queen captures with check
everything just falls into place after
artemiev played that a5 and allowed the
beautiful b5 push uh queen to f6
blocking and now knight captures on f5
we have king to f7 now comes queen to c7
offering the knight here but then you
lose the bishop so it doesn't really do
all that much plus you're in check so
first king to f8 and now we have rook to
e1 uh saying that okay now you can have
the knight not not the
the first time i mentioned it uh
but it's it's a problem if this is
captured we're gonna play queen captures
here attack the rook and once the rook
moves let's say you attack the queen
queen d6 and once the king moves let's
say c6 then c7 and it's game over
there's no stopping this and there's
really no way to pose any
threats to the
white king so instead after rookie one
we have queen to c3 attacking the rook
anyone and now white can do this in any
way
white wants and it's a very beautiful
position for example queen to e7 check
is a forced check made in 10 moves but
it's such a disgusting engine line that
even i will not show such a thing so
instead magnus plays the coolest human
move possible and that is queen captures
and c6 so he allows that timmy to
capture the rook on e1 with check which
of course he does queen captures here
king the g2 but now there are no more
checks e4 is covered by the queen and
the rook here is hanging and it doesn't
matter what you play
it's just gonna be a very very uh a
quick
end so here rook to a7 and now the
beautiful queen to f6 check and now look
at this uh if you block with the rook
then we just play queen to h8 checkmate
as the knight covers the e7 square if
you don't block with the rook if you
move the king let's say to g8 then
knight the h6 is checkmate uh also very
very beautiful stuff and another thing
after this king to e8 after this queen
to f6 check if king the e8 displayed
which was played in the game then magnus
uh plays uh c6 which he did
and he was in this position on move 35
that vladislav artemy resigned to the
game and game one of their match of the
semifinals goes to magnus cross and the
problem is now you can see the pawn
covers this knight covers this
and there's simply no defense how do you
defend against knight to d6 whatever you
do it's just game over uh even if queen
e4 check we're just gonna play king to
h2 now there are no more checks and
knight to d6 is just unstoppable the f7
square the d7 square has been taken away
from the black king and that's it
uh so after c6 after me resigned and a
great start for magnus in the
semi-finals of the air things masters uh
yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank ryan
urban uh cloud strife andre theron uh
cypher kicks and uh leo joel bourne for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day